one of the things that is a little
different in how we approach this is
that certifications does require a lot
of professional experience you have to
have hands-on experience with our tools
in order to do well in the certification
exams so that's not something that comes
easily with training but you know we we
definitely collaborate on kind of the
scope of our certifications and the
scope of the training but we do
emphasize that in addition to training
you need a lot of hands-on practice as
well
quick labs is one amazing way to get
that hands-on practice if you you know
maybe aren't using certain tools in your
day-to-day you can use labs to also get
some of that experience for our
professional certifications in
particular the multiple years of actual
professional experience is very critical
in order to perform well on those
certifications one of the challenges
with certification is in making sure
that you are for the individuals that
you're certifying actually have the
skills that we are saying that they have
and that's something that is is very
difficult to do but that's why we follow
a very rigorous process with the design
and the creation of the certifications
and it's something that we're constantly
looking to improve I think in addition
to that that's why we do recommend that
professional experience so that you're
not just kind of cramming for a test it
shouldn't be something that you just go
and you know hope that you pass but
really feeling confident in the skills
that you have and that's the that's one
of the goals of getting certified is
really increasing your confidence so
that you can go into these new projects
go into these customer meetings and have
confidence that you have the skills to
really perform well in your job role
you
you